If you start in data engineering, one of the things that people scream at you is learn SQL and learn Python.
They don't really ever really tell you why you should learn SQL and you should learn Python.
So in this video, we're going to be covering why you should learn SQL, why you should learn Python,
when you should use SQL, when you should use Python,
and all of the things that kind of make data engineering come together and come to life.
So yeah, let's get into it.
So first off, we have SQL.
So some of you might have noticed that it sometimes is called SQL.
Sometimes it's called SQL.
Both names are totally acceptable.
Generally speaking, the more experienced you get, you go from calling it SQL to calling it SQL.
Just because it's just a little bit fancier, right?
It's one less syllable, by the way.
There's a lot of history behind that because like there was two different versions of SQL like freaking 70 years ago or something like that.
And then like one was called SQL and one was called SQL.
And then they kind of like competed.
And so like, then they became the same thing, essentially.
It's a lot of culture there.
Definitely look it up if you're interested in that, but like at the end of the day,
SQL is used to transform data so you can use it to do things like count data.
So maybe you want to count how many times I logged in or count how many times I have liked posts different things like that That like aggregating data at Facebook we call that move fast and count things which is a very common like analytical
pattern. Another one is join. So sometimes you need to take two different data tables and two
different data sets and merge them together. And you need to use this on a join key, like,
so you can based on like user ID. So for example, like the data for the events might have a user ID
in it, but it doesn't have country. So say we want to know like the number of events by country,
then we have to join the user data where we have the user's country. And then we have the event
data that has the user and the event. And then you join those datas together and then aggregate.
And that can be a very powerful thing. So that's called join. Join is going to be the other most
important keyword that you use in SQL to create powerful data sets. If you know those two, you
know, join and group by, you're going to get very far. But let's cover just the other, you know,
simple keywords that are available in SQL. So you have select, which you just have to put at the top
to like list the columns that you are going to pick. This is kind of like the columns in Excel
that you would work with. And then you have where the where clause is just for filtering data so
that you can remove rows from the data table. So like if there's any bad data or whatever,
it very common to like filter out bad data or weird data in the where clause in your SQL query That the basics right You can do a couple other things right Like you might need to do a thing called insert into So this
is how you create new data. And we will be going over how to do insert into in the lab here in a
little bit. And you might also need to run a thing called delete. So that's where you delete data.
And then there's also an update command where you can update data. Someone changes their name or
they change their country or something like that. Those are going to be pretty much all of the
commands that you need to learn in SQL. It's actually pretty straightforward to learn. Like
we'll be going over all of these fundamentals here very soon. SQL is great, but it only can really
move data that is already in the warehouse or database or in the data lake. If it doesn't,
then SQL doesn't work as well. You need to use a different tool to get the data into the database
or into the data lake.
And that tool is almost always Python.
So Python is a programming language
that is actually designed to be very easy to learn.
It's way better to learn than like learning C++,
which is the first language I learned was C++.
And holy shit, C++ is such a bear to learn
compared to Python.
You use Python when you need to get data
that is outside of the warehouse.
Like maybe your data is in a Google Sheet,
or maybe your data is in Salesforce or maybe your data is anywhere else It could be a website or maybe it in OpenAI because you using AI to scrape data You can use OpenAI with Python
very easily. You use Python APIs to bring data in, and then you also use Python to schedule and
create your data pipelines. You can think of it as like SQL is like these big blocks that allow you
to transform data in a very efficient way. And then Python is the glue that puts everything
together. And those are going to be the two big tools and languages that you use in data engineering
to create in a very powerful way. There are situations in which you could use either tool,
Python or SQL, to solve the same problem. This is actually very common with a tool called PySpark.
In PySpark, right, you could write the same thing in Python that you could write in SQL.
They are interchangeable. Both Python and SQL can express each other. It's just very difficult for
SQL to access external things because it's designed to work in a very specific
data warehouse space and it's designed for data transformation, not data
extraction at the end of the day.
Like if you can learn these two tools, you will be well on your way to
becoming a very good data engineer.
So, uh, I will be creating a lab here in just a little bit.
So, uh, make sure to follow the next video in this series to catch that.